it's growing on me so nice of you to
stop by kevin enjoy your day i hope it's
productive thank you raymond i hope your
day is productive as well
pda in the office my my i couldn't help
myself
oh may i please use the precinct
facilities before i head to work yes
thank you for asking for permission
thank you for granting it
womp there it is
gotta say i could have used a little
more oomph on the womp that's the
oompheous one we'll get so what's going
on why'd you want to be in private i
need your help with a case three antique
coins were stolen from my classics
department at columbia so why not ask
captain holt for help on the case wait
are you guys getting a divorce
i can handle it this doesn't bring up
any weird issues for me no it's nothing
like that raymond's a brilliant
detective it's just when a case involves
me he can get a little over-emotional
you remember the safe house oh yeah he
went crazy but i also remember you and
me becoming best friends and watching
every nick cajun movie ever made can you
still quote them all no i purged myself
of that nonsense i bet it's still in
there that's nice
there's
that maybe it's there you're losing your
money okay so will you help me i don't
know i want to but keeping a secret from
holt that's a lot of pressure hmm am i
remembering correctly don't you
eat pressure for breakfast oh
nick cage in the rock we are best
friends i am so in
oh no that's raymond that's how he opens
a door kevin are you still in here uh
yes raymond i'm in the stall uh some
tickets were just released for mahler's
fourth symphony this weekend great that
sounds great let's do it fantastic now
which section do you prefer the first
tier
the second tier
the third tier the first here now which
section of the first tier
right
left right center
center just any section is fine any
section well someone had pepper on their
eggs this morning i'll buy the tickets
any section
ah perfect what what happened you know
where the bracelet is no kevin has
arrived with proof that i am the only
two-time winner of the highest here's
your comment bond raymond don't have
time for this sir i'm gonna go search
the first floor and i will search the
second floor we are an inseparable team
that was a devious fib i'm betraying her
even as we speak
again diaz and i are covertly working
together she snuck up through the vents
this is a major reveal i feel like
you're not appreciating i don't like
these heists or what they bring out in
you oh clement gevin clam it
cheddar perhaps we should leave no
cheddar stays he still has an important
role to play give me mr hoots with
no one would ever think of looking
before the bracelet in cheddar's
favorite chew toy or do you mean jake's
favorite chew toy
well thank god no one was around to hear
that
oh kevin's here you both look so upset
oh no did they stop funding the arts
they did but that doesn't matter anymore
nothing does cheddar has been kidnapped
someone took our fluffy boy oh my god
what happened well cheddar and i walked
to the bakery together we shared a plain
scone then we went to the park and i let
him off leash he
never came back someone took our fluffy
boy right you mentioned that now just to
be clear you didn't actually see someone
take him right so there's a chance
cheddar just ran away you know like some
dogs do cheddar isn't some dog he would
never do that someone took our fluffy
boy yes i understand i need you to drop
everything nothing in the world is as
important to me as this dog i wouldn't
say nothing for example you and i are
very close we don't have time for this i
think kidnappings the first 48 hours of
the most crucial right and in dog years
that's only seven hours why would you
say that this is why everyone prefers
that dog to you everyone okay look i'm
just saying that before we jump to any
conclusions we should consider the fact
that there's no actual proof that
someone kidnapped cheddar to text it
reads i have kidnapped your dog i see
well that seems like pretty hard proof
that's good good proof hello sir how'd
you find us out muller's fourth symphony
he'd never sit in just any section i
might i'm flexible oh really you'd sit
center left in timpani alley i'll
purchase those tickets right away
no don't fine jake is helping me with a
burglary here at the university and i
asked him not to tell you is this about
saint augustine yes what's going on he's
embarrassed of me last christmas the
classics department through a holiday
party i had one drink too many and
utterly
humiliated myself and that was the point
saint augustine was making in
consolation of philosophy yeah sounds
super humiliating saying something smart
smart i confused saint augustine with
boethius i might as well have stepped on
a rake and bonked myself in the forehead
the problem wasn't what you said it was
that dean alistair pointed out your
mistake and you lost your damn mind i
misremembered it because i'm reading
both simultaneously one book is too few
for me where's
it was quite the kerfuffle the problem
is is that i get flustered and defensive
because i know how they all see me
it's kevin's
working-class bimbo i can't imagine
that's what they think it is really
obviously i know that they're wrong but
they put you in your own head and you're
not yourself around them i'm sorry i was
just trying to protect you because of
course thank you for saving me from
myself now if you'll excuse me i'll just
go sit by the pool and read some fiction
like the bimbo that i am
there's a pool here
okay kevin we need to recreate your
morning and see if we can find some
clues all right cheddar and i entered on
the east side of the park over past
those trees
oh how we love those trees jake i don't
know if i can do this yeah you can do
this i'm right here with you we're gonna
get through it together now let's go
oh hey kev bud couldn't help but notice
that when i said let's go you didn't go
you stayed here and stared at that bench
tedder loved benches he'd run up to them
sniff their legs
or them with his paws sure that's what
you paw with i'm sorry this is
impossible everything i see reminds me
of cheddar the grass the asphalt
squirrels twitter love squirrels he
loves to chase them i suppose i should
say loved he'd never get there kevin
stop all right we need to get over to
that gate and recreate your morning and
if seeing all these things is too much
then just focus only on me all right
stare straight into my eyes very good i
will stare straight into your eyes okay
oh wow piercing
okay so let's do this
and we are headed to the east gate we're
doing great i think this is working i
can do this here we go i'm doing it
you're looking away no i'm not stop
moving away not don't look away but i
see leaves no twitter loved playing in
leaves didn't matter what kind oak maple
elem wait
i hate to cut you off but look what i
found security camera better love
security cameras how is that possible
and a big round of applause for janitor
randy for recovering our precious coin
don't applaud for that man what's going
on what's going on is captain holt just
solved this case what's there left to
solve we found the coin in professor
port's desk he's the thief oh you'd like
everyone to believe that wouldn't you
dean aleister or should i say general
parmenion raymond are you causing a
kerfuffle yes sometimes the moment calls
for a kerfuffle no no moment calls for a
kerfuffle you know my feelings on this
dean alistair framed professor port to
get rid of a rival just as alexander got
rid of parminion preposterous do you
even have a shred of evidence to back up
that claim oh we've got more than a
shred look at these photos here a
footprint from the scene of the crime
left by the thief and here another print
made yesterday by you you've been caught
alistair is it happening caught by me it
is happening me and my rock hard brain
it happened oh raymond look around these
shoes i'm wearing with their unique
footprint we all have them they were the
departmental gift this christmas they're
actually very funny they have achilles
printed on the heel i don't know if i
would call that very funny i'm surprised
you didn't know about them kevin must
have gotten a pair oh i remember what
happened you had to leave the christmas
party before they were handed out why
was that again oh yes but kerfuffle but
what about the autobiography of
persimmons you were taunting us with i
suppose i can see how holding any book
would seem like a taunt to you i own a
book i don't think raymond is
remembering the story correctly
alexander didn't see parminion as a
rival he killed him over a dispute about
his son oh no it's boethius all over
again at least you've got one thing
right you do have a rock-hard brain
because that's bad everyone knows that a
brain should be soft and wet i wanted to
say that but jake told me not to yeah
because it's gross
well hello there raymond teach me kevin
and i am detective jacob peralta he
didn't have anything else to wear so he
just switched
he understands
[Music]
okay if we're gonna pull this off we
need to teach you how to move talk and
act exactly like kevin in other words we
have ourselves a pygmalion situation
exactly a pig mailman situation right
it'll be okay well it'll be okay let's
get started yes let's get started it's
getting worse spot on kevin look raymond
a yellow yellow-crusted warbler a
greymund a yellow-crested warbler no
you're too excited the warbler is a
common bird and then i said which
metamorphosis kafka or ovid
i loved it he loves it oh so that's the
joke now you tell it oh okay
so a professor walks into a rare book's
collection no you've ruined it no it's
not funny look raymond a yellow-crested
warbler look raymond a yellow-crusted
word ugh not excited enough they may be
common but they're still birds the 92nd
street y had a wonderful symposium on
just that topic that's it you're getting
it ah
don't say cool instead say indeed oh
indeed indeed indeed indeed indeed
that's weird look raymond a
yellow-crusted warbler yes that's the
right level of excitement for such a
bird you captured the essence of kevin
you've done it correction i've
accomplished it indeed indeed indeed
indeed
it's growing on me yeah i stole those
coins i can't believe you bought that
whole story they underestimated you
randy just as they underestimated
raymond holt you guys haven't been that
great to me either well you got to teach
people how you want to be treated randy
dr phil r.i.p the point is captain holt
solved the case when no one else could
he's actually been stealing from these
archives for years you've been asleep at
the wheel alastair you're an
embarrassment really well at least i've
never confused scent augustine with
boethius oh who gives a rat's ass about
boethius wesley what are you doing kevin
i'm creating a kerfuffle oh damn sure my
husband is a hot piece of ass but he is
so much more than just that raymond holt
is as smart as anyone in this department
but he chooses to use his intelligence
to make our city a better place
one day i hope to live up to the
standard you set
you make me want to have
a wetter brain
i'm kevin
[Music]
y'all are hella specific
you